something kind of big just happened with
nuclear weapons Russia pulled out of a
treaty that bans countries from testing
their nukes which is an important
measure we take to stop countries from
getting into a nuclear arms race like we
had during the Cold War Russia and the
United States have 89% of all the
nuclear weapons in the world and for a
long time they kept competing against
each other on who could get more to
deescalate this they did a lot of stuff
but one of the things they did was sign
this treaty that basically said like
let's not test nuclear weapons which
would provoke each other to like want to
ratchet up how many we each have the US
signed it too but never ratified it so
they didn't actually commit to it so
Russia by pulling out of the treaty is
like hey we're just doing what the US
has been doing this whole time which is
I mean true so now Russia can test
nuclear weapons whenever they want
though they say they have no plans to do
so the big worry here is if they do
they're going to set a bad example for
other countries who also want nuclear
weapons and potentially spark another
arms race if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more